bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo 45 minutes d'actualité politique
avec moracchini bonjour jour michael et
bonjour à tous on va commencer cette
semaine politique avec entre autres des
journées parlementaires des partis de la
gauche les verts était à nantes le front
de gauche en région parisienne et
l'ensemble du gouvernement et
parlementaires socialistes étaient eux
réunis à dijon les sujets de friction
étaient nombreux parmi ces sujets le
premier test pour la majorité c'est le
traité budgétaire européen présenté en
conseil des ministres il divise la
gauche les communistes une partie des
écologistes et quelques membres de
l'ailé gauche du ps
combattre le projet de loi tandis que le
premier ministre appelle à la solidarité
et un vote massif et puis nous parlerons
de ses caricatures qui déchaîne les
passions charlie hebdo qui donnait pas
son coup d'essai public cette semaine
des dessins qui tourne en dérision le
prophète mahomet colère embarras à la
tête de l'état le débat sur la liberté
de la presse mais d'engager est avec
nous pour commenter l'actualité cette
semaine jean vincent placé merci d'être
avec nous sur ce plateau
là vous êtes depuis près d'un an
sénateur de l'essonne président du
groupe écologiste sénat on peut dire que
vous êtes un homme politique heureux
puisque vous êtes d'abord réussi à
négocier un groupe au sénat vous avez
aussi négocié l'accord avec le ps c'est
donc on peut le dire un peu grâce à vous
si votre parti qui a fait 2 % à
l'élection présidentielle se retrouve
aujourd'hui 17 députés à l'assemblée et
deux ministres gouvernement là dessus
vos amis écolos vous sont plutôt
reconnaissant jérémy arman leur a tendu
le micro lors de vos journées
parlementaires regardez jean vincent est
vrai était plutôt au départ un homme
d'appareil dix ans quand il est venu
chez les verts il ya une dizaine
d'années je sais qu'il a été levée dans
le milieu des avocats qui m'est cher et
que son père est avocat je crois qu'il
est encore d'ailleurs et que donc
peut-être il y a acquis cette espèce de
de d'habitude de la dialectique de la
négociation et qu'il aime ça les gens
savent ce que nous lui devons dans la
construction politique dans laquelle
nous sommes actuellement avec qui veut
que celui présent dans les deux
assemblées le sénat l'assemblée
nationale que nous soyons présents au
gouvernement un moment on l'a bien vu
essayer d'être ministre pour lui je
montre à un petit peu il adore les
caméras tout ça ça pas marché qu'il est
parfois critiquée parce que il dit les
choses c'est franchement et directement
sans détour j'ai toujours regardé avec
beaucoup de distance les mâles dans la
testostérone amène à mener le ton un peu
haut
ils font centre on est jamais trop
ambition politique une certain qu'il le
dit en plus
est ce que cela lui portera tort il est
possible que ça peut être un handicap
quand on montre trop les dents et lui
montre les dents mois jean vincent placé
ça commençait bien ça en dégénérant un
petit peu donc bon négociateur ça certes
mais un peu trop ambitieux c'est une
qualité en politique mais c'est pas une
qualité ou un défaut c'est moi j'ai dit
des choses d'ailleurs c'est toujours
terrible c'est que ça troue tout le
monde trouve normal que quelqu'un de
l'ump ou du ps ou même un communiste a
exercé des responsabilités je sais pas
pourquoi les verts soit on est des babas
cool en sandales
na na na na pas du tout blessé y ait un
côté caricatural systématiquement et
soit alors quand on devient sérieux
institutionnels crédit b je pense à plus
compétents sur quelques dossiers
ça y est tout de suite on sensu siona
lisent en est on veut avoir absolument
les postes de prix etc n'ont attendu
animal politique non mais c'est vrai je
pense que c'est moi qui aie ça c'est
nicolas sarkozy c'est que qu'on va faire
la politique il faut mettre politique
voilà comme ça j'ai toujours dit et puis
nos ambitions ananas qui compte c'est la
conviction moi je veux dire je suis en
plus personnellement de d'une famille
plutôt d'origine de droite eu le sol de
toute ma famille depuis l'ensemble des
générations à voter à gauche est
vraiment c'était pas du tout pour me
fâcher avec mes parents c'est parce que
c'est ces conceptions personnelles des
valeurs de la gauche et chez assume de
dire je suis devenu écologiste grâce à
michel crépeau grâce à des gens comme
françois de rugy aussi ou noël mamère
que j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer
quand j'étais assistante dentaire ne pas
être entré au gouvernement ben waters
alors là je vais vous dire qu'alain
totalement franc pas du tout mais alors
pas du tout je n'ai pas on dirait une
seconde ça paraissait logique après ce
parcours justement
d'institutionnalisation du mouvement et
y compris le fait d'avoir des
responsabilités comme pour ma part au
sénat puis avec le souci de vouloir
apporter au pays à la france pour lequel
j'ai une passion mais je suis un
passionné de la france donc voilà mais
pas du tout pourquoi parce que déjà nous
représentons cécile duflot ee pascal
canfin ils sont remarquables je n'ai pas
fait un petit contrôle gaza
puis comme par ailleurs on le sait sur
le pacte budgétaire européen sur la loi
organique sur la politique fiscale et
budgétaire j'ai quand même pas mal de
nuances
si beaucoup plus et voilà je vais vous
dire donc des convictions parce que ça
c'est très important et c'est celle-là
la gauche l'écologie l'écologie dans la
libre parole bosser bosser mais pas que
la libre parole parce que moi je veux
poser et c'est ça qui fait le truc c'est
la question du pouvoir et moi je la pose
très clairement parce que comme
justement la crise écologique est de
plus en plus vives eh bien on a besoin
de changer les choses et rapidement
alors on va développer tout ce qui s'est
passé cette semaine est bon cela dit
c'est une tribune qui est publié dans le
monde qui pose politique
ils sont 75 députés et signe une tribune
dans le monde il veut le faire respecter
la proposition numéro 52 françois
hollande le droit de vote des étrangers
aux élections locales pas une priorité
l'ordi manuel valls le point ministre
dit que ce sera respectée le reportage
de jean baptiste daoulas le texte a des
airs de rappel à l'ordre
75 députés socialistes font la une du
monde avec une tribune ils réclament le
droit de vote aux élections locales pour
les immigrés installés légalement en
france depuis au moins cinq ans c'était
l'un des engagements de françois
hollande pendant la campagne le droit de
vote aux résidents étrangers aux
élections municipales et sans qu'il
puisse être éligible à la fonction de
maire ou d'adjoint n'a rien à voir avec
je ne sais quel soumission à telle ou
telle religion et pourquoi donc
mais plutôt à voir avec l'intégration et
le respect de ceux qui payent des impôts
ici et peuvent aux élections locales
participer au scrutin
mais aujourd'hui le droit de vote des
étrangers n'est pas la priorité du
gouvernement
la faute à un calendrier parlementaire
engorgé par le traité budgétaire
européen et les lois de finances
au rayon des réformes de société le
mariage homosexuel est passé avant le
droit de vote des étrangers
le ministre de l'intérieur manuel valls
estime m
il n'y a pas d'urgence bien évidemment
il n'y a pas d'urgence au sens
économique du terme ou au sens social du
terme c'est évident mais en y regardant
de plus près je pense qu'il ya une
urgence de cohésion sociale dans notre
pays le président de la république l'a
dit tout au long de la campagne
et bien aujourd'hui il faut que nous
donnions des signes pendant la campagne
françois hollande avait évoqué l'année
2013 pour instaurer le droit de vote des
étrangers
une date que les signataires de la
tribune seront lui rappelait jean
vincent placé on va rappeler simplement
que le sénat a déjà voté une proposition
de loi dans ce sens une proposition de
loi qui émanait de votre groupe
les verts manuel valls qui vous dit qui
dit à l'ensemble de la gauche c'est pas
une priorité du moment où il a tort
predator n'est sûr que il a tort on en a
parlé beaucoup pendant la campagne
présidentielle le président françois
mitterrand on avait proposé en 1940 en
dragueur donc ça fait 30 ans que ça dure
ça déjà trop duré le premier ministre a
redit bien les choses ce sera aux
experts au premier trimestre 2013
d'ailleurs vous savez comment ça se
passait les projets de loi les
propositions noir issu du parlement
si ça n'arrivait pas assez vite nous
mêmes nous proposerions par voie
parlementaire d'accélérer le processus
et soca c'est essentiel il ya je crois
un 8 millions d'étrangers qui sont là
depuis plus de cinq ans en france
ils sont dans les associations où ils
sont dans les parents d'élèves ils sont
dans les conseils de prud'hommes enfin
bon voilà c'est bien naturel et ses
forces de cohésion d'intégration et par
rapport au parti
oui mais même au genre je vous dire moi
je suis pour même aller plus loin
même pour qu'il y ait des maires
adjoints des mères à terme voilà donc
mais après on a trouvé un accord avec le
parti socialiste pour justement pour
qu'on aille sur les élus locaux qui ne
sont pas dans les exécutifs qui ne sont
pas d'ailleurs des élus pour des
électeurs pour les sénatoriales
et je crois que le projet loi très
équilibrée et d'ouvert et puis il appert
les maîtres qui correspond à une logique
politique et portait pas présent appeler
par le premier ministre parlant sans
majorité et donc j'espère que ça va bien
se passer au premier tour très politique
jean vincent placé eelv à faudra pour
changer la constitution
à voir ce qu'on appelle les 3/5 pour
cela ou pour l'instant la gauche et la
majorité sénatoriale et parlementaires à
l'assemblée
mais c'est pas suffisant et montrant du
doigt un manque trop de voir vous allez
chercher ou au centre
il faut pas chercher ailleurs forcément
donc les socialistes le parti communiste
nous les écologistes et ont commencé à
parler au sénat ce soit les socialistes
les verts on a eu une discussion déjà au
sénat à l'automne dernier vous le
rappeliez donc conduit oui mais on
discute
moi je sais trés pas forcément les gens
mais on discute évidemment avec le modem
avec eux les les centristes qui sont
républicains ont voilà donc rapidement
tout plutôt qu'un référendum parce que
on pouvait la jolie derniers sondages
que les français moi je suis particulier
dans ceux dans ce pays si j'ose dire
c'est que je suis opposé ils sont du
président au suffrage universel direct
longtemps mais bon je sais c'est pas
l'objet du jour donc je ne développe pas
je suis opposé au référendum
à la différence de mes petits camarades
y compris européens qui est en une
passion pour tous les référendums sauf
sur la question européenne mais ça on y
reviendra donc moi je suis constant je
suis pas pour les référendum après le
président la république lui a pris des
engagements il a dit si ça passe pas au
congrès je fais référendum
donc moi je soucieux de soutenir
fidèlement le président appelait
d'accord mais la politique ça consiste
pas à chaque fois à mesurer le fait que
ça soit certain que le président
république a été candidat je suis pas
persuadé qu'il ya 18 mois il était sûr
d'être élu donc voilà un moment il faut
être courageux
moi je suis pas un peu plus jeudi pour
le fai référendaire mais qu'à partir du
moment où le président a vu et l'a dit
il faut qu'il tienne ses engagements à
les lundis toujours un autre député
socialiste fait l'actualité c'est rené
dosière le député de l'aisne éternel
pourfendeur des gabegies de l'état sur
un livret fait une conférence de presse
il propose 50 propositions pour
économiser 15 à 20
liards d'euros petit résumé avec elisa
bertolo mèche 50 propositions pour un
état exemplaire et parmi elles une
réforme des collectivités territoriales
une manne financière colossale qui
engendre de nombreux gaspillages leur
volume est énorme 240 milliards
bon et avec une croissance très forte et
donc si on organise et mieux les
collectivités locales
et bien c'est l'une des réformes que je
propose à ce moment là on aurait une
croissance des dépenses moins forte et
on pourrait faire le 15 à 20 milliards
d'économies propositions majeures du
député regrouper la commune et
l'intercommunalité
ce nouvel échelon permettrait de
réaliser des économies de personnel et
de services mais d'autres institutions
de l'état sont aussi pointés du doigt
par exemple rené dosière invite l'elysée
et le gouvernement à diminuer leurs
effectifs et préconise de soumettre à
l'impôt
l'indemnité de fonction des
parlementaires quand on fait des
économies en matière de train de vie
telle qu'on l'entend
les économies sont faibles mais leur
valeur d'exemplarité n'a pas de prix
elle est considérable et si on ne le
fait pas on ne pourra pas demander aux
français de faire des efforts des
mesures plus symbolique que rentable au
delà des économies
le député veut montrer aux citoyens que
leurs élus ne vivent pas en dehors de la
réalité alors jean vincent placé on va
s'arrêter sur une proposition à qui vous
concerne directement puisque rené
dosière suggère que soit supprimée la
réserve parlementaire du sénat de quoi
s'agit-il
environ 120 milles euros par-ci nateur
qui sont attribuées pour financer des
projets dans vos circonscriptions ce que
n'aime pas rené dosière c'est que en
quelque sorte à favoriserait en
favorisant certaines mairies les
sénateurs s'achèterait quelques voix de
grands électeurs vous êtes d'accord avec
ça elle c'est une vision complètement
caricaturale la vie politique ça aurait
donc dire qu'à chaque fois que par
exemple un président un gouvernement
propose une mesure en destination de tel
ou tel territoire du telle ou telle
catégorie d'objets spécifiques
d'élection des sénateurs qui fait que
ces mêmes mer sont compris dans telle ou
telle association au niveau national
c'est les gens qui sont l'association
plaisir avant les achète et ses
terrasses et quand même
vision extrêmement caricaturale
concrètement votre votre réserve
parlementaire 140 midi lorsque je crois
que c'est tout le monde et nous à gauche
qu'on est arrivés on a pris la somme
globale et on l'a divisé par le nombre
de sénateurs y compris ceux de
l'opposition alors que quand nous étions
nous dans l'opposition il y avait des
sommes assez mirifiques pour tel ou tel
grand dignitaire du sénat amendis
comprenne bien
alors ça finance des projets des
collectivités locales moi j'écris
terry's sur les projets écolo donc il ya
une commune l'unique communes d'île de
france et dans mon département
évidemment qui a installé des éoliennes
c'est notamment grâce à mike il ya des
éoliennes en ile de france
et puis des écoles des crèches désastre
des structures solidarité mois en gros c
les projets écolo les projets de
solidarité des projets démocratie votre
exemple personnel mais vous avez bien
que les autres sénateurs eux d'appliquer
attention moi j'ai mis ça tout dans ma
danger une petite feuille que tu
distribues voilà il ya un petit tableau
ce que je pense qui est important c'est
la transparence absolue de la même
manière que d'ailleurs pour les frais de
mandat je pense que on doit dire ce
qu'on fait ce qu'on dépense mais après
moi je le dis très tranquillement
le parlement français a longtemps été
croupion d'un cinquième république il ya
pas beaucoup de moyens il ya des moyens
pour les sénateurs les députés il ya des
moyens pour l'administration il ya pas
de moyens de bien travailler
par exemple on a un nom de
collaborateurs ridicule par rapport à
même d cabinet de maire de dix quinze
vingt mille habitants
et je peux vous dire que quand on
devient jeune sénateur comme moi on
cumule pas on comprend pourquoi les
autres voulaient cumulé parce que
justement on a peu de moyens pour faire
la loi
expertise et contrôler et évaluer la
dépense publique est là dessus voyez aux
états unis moi je suis pas un fanatique
des états unis sur le plan de la
démocratie
mais le congrès et le sénat américain ça
marche comme ils ont des collaborateurs
transparence jean vincent placé on va
parler de votre parti nous sommes mardi
et les parlementaires verts sont réunis
pour 24 heures
avec un groupe à l'assemblée et un autre
au sénat les parlementaires verts
prennent du poids et le font grandement
sentir à leur partenaire de la majorité
notamment au parti socialiste ils sont
venus participer à cette journée
parlementaire
un autre c'est un reportage de canal car
aux journées parlementaires d'europe
écologie les verts delphine batho la
ministre de l'écologie était venu
assurer le service après-vente de la
conférence environnementale je viens
d'abord pour pour parler de la
transition énergétique et aussi de des
résultats de la conférence
environnementale que je conçois
seulement comme un point de départ
donc il reste beaucoup de travail à
accomplir ensemble une conférence
environnementale qui a surtout permis
d'atténuer les tensions entre verts et
socialistes sur le nucléaire ou encore
le gaz de schiste on a eu je crois
quelques mois ou fallait que la nouvelle
majorité et notamment au sein du
gouvernement se calent beaucoup de
nouveaux ministres quelques maladresses
des ajustements de portefeuilles
mais surtout ce lien écologie sortie de
crise économique sortie crise sociale a
été affichée donc c'est un bon cap
mais d'autres questions pourraient venir
semer la discorde parmi les
parlementaires écologistes en haut de la
liste le futur traité budgétaire
européen
le dscg et sur ce point cécile duflot
préfère prendre des gants et botter en
touche
moi ce qui guident mon action et ma
conviction politique c'est bien le cap
qu'on va fixer à l'europe les moyens
qu'on va donner à cette politique le
soutien à ce président de la république
de gauche dans un univers politiques
européens qui n'est pas favorable à nos
idées en suspens aussi la question
épineuse de l'aéroport de notre dame des
landes jean marc ayrault qui soutient ce
projet avait d'ailleurs été invités à
ces journées parlementaires
il a finalement décliné l'invitation
jean vincent placé vous êtes partenaires
vous êtes alliés mais apparemment la
lune de miel a visiblement de ce qu'on
comprend sur pas mal de thèmes s'est
promenée mariage c'est pas toujours la
ligne deviennent pour aller plus loin ça
veut dire qu'il ya une forme au des
problèmes avec le parti socialise notre
accord a tenu finalement qu on a trois
quatre mois mais non mais l'accord il
est là nous sommes dans la majorité une
soutenance précision la république et
c'est pas ça pour vous y'a pas il faut
pas avoir de vision puéril de la vie
politique dont on n'est pas moi je suis
pas parti socialiste gilles sont
beaucoup plus productive et ce que nous
très lourdement même parfois ils ont
même les vision industrielle assez
classique du passé et peut-être une
petite tendance un peu libérale on le
voit aussi ou alors à toujours tout
ménagé bon voilà donc ça fait peut-être
d'ailleurs la force d'un parti de
gouvernement et ils sont là c'est très
bien nous nous voulons pas seulement
être l'aiguillon le poil à gratter nous
voulons peser dans un temps politique où
les françaises et les français
d'ailleurs ils ont montré l'exemple
essentiel que ce n'est pas forcément
très réceptifs à nos idées nous nous
pensons que nous sommes importants dans
la majorité parce que justement les
enjeux de la planète sont là aussi peu à
l'étroit dans cette majorité d'accords
rapport de force que les françaises et
français ont acté donc on a fait un très
mauvais score aux présidentielles
quelque part je suis sûr que ça a pesé
dans les réflexions des de nos
gouvernants dans les trois premiers mois
je suis très content aussi du cap
général de
françois hollande à la conférence
environnemental où il indique justement
ce lien extrêmement important de la
transition énergétique et écologique qui
n'est pas un frein à l'emploi qui n'est
pas un frein au développement ça c'est
notre axe principal on dit protéger la
planète
faire en sorte que des emplois soient là
notamment les emplois durables et non
délocalisables que le pays soit dans le
redressement dans la justice donc ça ce
sont ces thèmes-là l'environnement n'est
pas sacrifiée sur l'autel de la crise
grecque
justement on verra si vite pourquoi
pourquoi françois hollande et j'ai cette
modestie de le penser pourquoi françois
hollande fait aussi ce discours c'est
parce qu'il fait certains arbitrages et
que c'est un visionnaire et c'est un bon
président mais c'est aussi parce qu'on
est dans la prairie bien sûr mais c'est
aussi parce qu'on est là et pourquoi ça
peut être une petite chance de se
réaliser malgré le traité européen
malgré la rigueur et l'austérité
budgétaire c'est aussi parce qu'on est
là parce que nous pendant la loi de
finances qui arrive est sur le même
financement la sécurité sociale on va
peser sur nos thématiques la
biodiversité la santé environnement la
fiscalité écologique et voilà et ce qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui la force en vérité
les écologistes et même par les deux
groupes parlementaires ouais je dis très
franchement c'est l'urgence déjà des
idées écologistes et d'autre part le
fait que les citoyens même si encore ils
ont difficulté à voter pour nous dans
les élections sérieuse type présidentiel
ils sont préoccupés et le sentent tous
les jours je sais pas si on parlera des
ogm et vous avez vu d'étude des sorties
vous moi j'ai porté le débat sur le
diesel et les particules fines qui font
40 me le décès par an voilà donc moi je
suis pas dans le catastrophisme j'alerte
les françaises et les français qu'on est
quand même en danger pour la planète est
en danger pour leur santé juste une
toute petite question subsidiaire une
curiosité vous il n'y avait pas eva joly
lors des journées parlementaires elle
n'est plus la bienvenue on avait la fête
de l'huma même pas cher c'est une bonne
question il n'y avait pas non plus
daniel cohn bendit poser non ils sont
tous le bien du tout le bienvenu chacun
bien d'accord gardez toujours céder la
date limite de dépôt des parrainages
pour les candidats à la présidence de
l'ump alors au siège du parti c'est
presque par brouettes entières
qu'arrivent les parrainages de françois
fillon et jean françois copé
les autres candidats n'ont pas eu le
nombre de parrainages suffisants
yoann cela
des dizaines de cartons décharger d'une
camionnette les parrainages de jean
françois copé sont arrivés à la
mi-journée au siège de l'ump
trente-deux mille signatures annoncent
le camp du secrétaire général du parti
il est alors sûrs d'être en tête je suis
très heureux de voir
nombre aussi important de militants qui
m'ont apporté leur soutien dans cette
première phase
et ça m'a énormément ému par ce que je
vois bien derrière cela qu'il y à une
adhésion à un projet auquel nous croyons
profondément les uns et les autres pour
la reconstruction de notre famille
politique mais en fin d'après-midi qu'au
théâtre
nous avons reçu à ce jour 40 le chiffre
a été gardé secret jusqu'à la dernière
minute il dépasse de loin celui qui
était avancée dans la matinée les
cartons sont plus gros et plus nombreux
la bataille de l'image bat son plein les
apports d'autres candidats
je veux aller là
volume que cela
il ya une confiance forte des militants
ou delà des candidats six motions ont
été déposées par les différents courants
du parti
ces candidatures doivent désormais être
vérifiée et les parrainages contrôler un
par un on travaille sous contrôle
d'huissier qui prendra une dizaine de
jours quand vous regardez ça d'un peu
loin bien évidemment vous avez connu
vous même des affres de primaires
internes plein d'autres gens plutôt copé
ou plutôt fillon même si vous voyez ça
de loin
bon moi je suis un politique alors je
préfère les plus politiques donc mais je
suis pas sûr ça va lui rendre service
donc il me semble que le secrétaire
général sortant serait plus adapté à la
bataille politique mais après voilà
c'est le fion moi je trouve qu'il a le
bilan de sarkozy sans les qualités de
sarkozy voilà on va passer au mercredi
c'est un texte que vous sous lequel vous
vous intéressez bien sûr énormément
c'est le texte sur le traité européen
qui arrive en conseil des ministres
jean-vincent placé le texte arrivera
début octobre à l'assemblée puis un
petit peu plus tard au sénat ils ont
venimeux bien sûr les relations entre
les alliés de la majorité alors mais qui
est il exactement
dans ce texte quelques éléments de
réponse avec elisa berthelot mais deux
chapitres composent ce pacte budgétaire
européen
premier volet le traité sur la
coordination la stabilité et la
gouvernance signé par nicolas sarkozy le
2 mars
il complète les règles déjà en vigueur
en europe et fixe un objectif
les états doivent maintenir leur déficit
structurel en dessous de 0,5 pour cent
du pib
c'est la fameuse règle d'or le traité
arrive au parlement le 2 octobre
mais le gouvernement doit encore
convaincre les députés de le voter
plus le message parlementaire aps le
vote sera fort plus la voix de la france
sera forte et plus pourront continuer à
travailler à la réorientation de
l'europe
voilà le sens de la proposition que fait
le gouvernement devant le parlement pour
être appliqué ce traité doit être
traduit en droit français c'est le
deuxième volet le projet de loi
organique relative aux finances
publiques
trois propositions majeures vont être
soumises au vote du parlement
l'encadrement des crédits budgétaires et
des dépenses sociales la création d'un
haut conseil des finances publiques
placée sous l'autorité de la cour des
comptes
sorte de vigie budgétaire cette
institution se prononcera sur les
prévisions de croissance du gouvernement
et sur leur respect la création enfin
d'un mécanisme de correction en cas
d'écarts importants par rapport aux
objectifs de redressement des finances
publiques
un traité sévère que françois hollande a
cherché à adoucir en contrepartie de la
règle d'or
le président français a négocié un pacte
pour la croissance de 120 milliards
d'euros sur trois ans jean vincent placé
on connaît votre position vous êtes
contre ce texte
déjà première question est ce que
françois hollande qui devait
renégociation texte at il tenu parole
oui non françois hollande il a renégocié
et la situation
économique et budgétaire et fiscale
incontestablement avec ce qu'il appelle
le panneau croissance qui a été présenté
les 28 et 29 juin à bruxelles
et les fameux 120 milliards soixante
berry en vérité que 10 mais ça fait
effet levier les 55 des fonds
structurels et les cinq de project band
cependant très bien il compris hier sur
des projets écolo après tout le monde le
reconnaît d'ailleurs on est obligé de
reconnaître il n'a pas été renégocié ce
traité pourquoi parce que trenet c'est
comme un contrat qui lie ces deux textes
à la virgule près en effet très content
non j'ai pas que pour ça c'est parce que
c'est parce que effectivement c'est
mercado sarkozy c'est merkozy comme
disait d'ailleurs cohn-bendit à l'époque
et il disait d'ailleurs beaucoup de mal
de ce traité et pouvait pas que les
auteurs c'est la réalité vous l'avais
dit dans votre très bon reportage c'est
la perspective du déficit structurel
constamment à l' équilibre c'est à dire
qu'il n'y aura plus de politique
budgétaire
ça veut dire aussi qu'il y aura des
contraintes mécaniques très fort qu'ils
pensent de civette part je suis désolé
de dire quelques technocrates de
bruxelles et personnes de très légitime
parce que le parlement européen vous
l'aurez constaté est complètement absent
du dispositif il était absent pour faire
le traité il était absent pour débattre
et l'absent pour le contrôler et puis
par ailleurs il ya un élément qui a été
oubliée mais qui est souvent oublié
c'est que en plus du déficit structurel
à moins de 0,5
on nous incite à revenir sur la dette
globale ses terres actuellement on la
dette aidé à 90% du pib' et il faudra
aller à 60 et d'ici vingt ans que ça va
être encore plus de rigueur et
d'austérité
moi je suis en plus pour le
désendettement parce que les 600
milliards sarkozy doit être le poids de
la dette est quand même suffisant c'est
vitam aeternam moi et je porte un nom
fédéraliste parce que justement je
voulais qu au niveau européen
il y ait un gouvernement économique
qu'il y ait une fiscalité qui est des
marges de manoeuvre aujourd'hui le
budget européen il est quand même très
faible il faut aller au delà
donc s'il ya plus de politique
budgétaire en france et dans les états
membres et qui en a pas non plus à
bruxelles
ça veut dire que c'est le
archer qui va guider et ça veut dire
aussi qu'on ne pense plus que la
puissance publique peut être offensive
ycompris sur la politique industrielle
d'où le débat que nous portons nous d
écologie sur la conversion écologique de
l'économie soit énergies renouvelables
sur la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments sur le transport crise il faut
de l'argent et nous on veut non pas d
une question jean marc ayrault l'a bien
dit il a signifié il veut un vote massif
les verts visiblement peut-être votre
encontre en tout cas c'est votre avis
personnel vous voterez compte oui c'est
quoi il ya un véritable problème il a
tort de demander le vote massif sur
certaines îles ce qui pourrait être
réellement mécontents se sont justement
ceux qui auquel on avait dit que le
traité à être négociées je viens de
l'expliquer je crois en quelques mots il
ne l'est pas bon il ya un pari sur
l'avenir
moi je pense que quelques carrés sur un
plan politique nationale hors des
revenus un petit peu sur mes verres de
contact écologie sont moins affirmatifs
que vous n'avez pascal canfin appel à
l'abstention cécile duflot je n'entends
pas normal les jeunes déjà vous savez en
temps normal le ministre généralement il
est là pour dire oui aux chefs de
gouvernement et pascal canfin de façon
assez courageux je le dis moi il dit
déjà abstention déjà le ministre nuit et
10 abstentions
alors il affirmé mais le positif
on peut pas moi je pense que moi je suis
pour la parole libre déjà j'ai aucun
problème et même je vais vous dire ça va
vous surprendre
quand montebourg dit qu'il épaule
nucléaire ou valls dit qu'il est contre
le droit de vote des étrangers ça me
choque pas puis il parle
et moi je suis pour le débat à la
différence de ce qui se faisait avant et
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça j'en arrive à
la conclusion que déjà les ministres ils
racontent ce qu'ils veulent
françois rebsamen qui est un ami et est
opposé au non cumul des mandats
bon ben voilà donc pour lui on vient pas
le caporal easy françois rebsamen donc
donc il y aura je pense des députés
socialistes qui vont voter contre moi et
avec nombre de mes collègues chez
attention de voter contre et par
ailleurs je vais vous dire très
clairement y compris parce que justement
j'ai ce raisonnement là s'il ya des
parlementaires écologistes qui veulent
voter oui parce que c'est leur
conviction et ben voilà c'est important
parce que ça doit être comme ça de la
démocratie parce que la caporalisation
l'a vu chez sarkozy
il faisait petite réunion le matin ils
envoyaient des sms aux avec des éléments
de langage les élans
langage enfin deux jours tout le monde
raconté la même histoire et on a vu où
ça mène
et ce qui est très important c'est ne
pas tuer le débat et de se respecter et
je sais que premier ministre respectons
continue la semaine jean vincent placé
mercredi toujours charlie hebdo récidive
dans les caricatures de mahomet dans un
contexte marqué par les manifestations
anti-américaines l'hebdomadaire
satirique publie des dessins carré culte
caricaturant le prophète initiative
accueillie évidemment avec embarras par
les autorités françaises ahmed tazir en
une ce dessin un musulman fauteuil
roulant poussé par un juif orthodoxe
avec ce titre intouchable 2 après le
film anti-islam diffusée sur internet et
la manifestation à paris la semaine a
été très tendue mais le directeur de
charlie hebdo 1 reste serein pas de
menaces pour l'instant on en a j'ai pas
de nouvelles en tout cas de ce côté là
et puis protégée par la police a fait un
an qu'on est protégée par la police
depuis l'incendié des derniers locaux et
voilà si c'est la condition pour
s'exprimer librement en france bon ben
on sera protégé de projets protégé par
la police
mais là où charlie voix liberté
d'expression le conseil français du
culte musulman voit une provocation
la liberté d'expression ne peut pas être
ne peut pas justifier les insultes et la
haine à l'incitation à la haine
je ne pense pas que que ce couvert de la
liberté d'expression une personne peut
insulter une autre personne les
autorités par la voix du premier
ministre invoque la liberté de
caricature tout en désapprouvant les
excès si vraiment des personnes se sont
heurtés dans la conviction et pense
qu'il ya eu dépassement du droit nous
sommes dans un état de droit c'est ed
rock tac droit doit être totalement
respectée
elles peuvent saisir les tribunaux ça
s'est déjà produit concernant aussi cet
hebdomadaire et jean marc ayrault de
prévenir la demande de manifester samedi
prochain à paris pour protester contre
le film anti-islam sera rejetée par
mesure de précaution les ambassades
consulats écoles françaises seront
fermés dans une vingtaine de pays
musulmans
vendredi jour de grande prière on a vu
jean marc ayrault cas une réponse un
petit peu alambiqué un peu embarrassé la
liberté de la presse
explique jean marc ayrault très
équilibré pas du tout embarrassé il a
dit la vie personnelle c'est quoi au
juste à cordes jean marc ayrault liberté
de la presse la liberté sur les
caricatures aussi nuls souhaité l
lens manque un petit peu de la religion
c'est là ça peut passer dans ce débat
politique de la politique on embête le
président habib sy sur sa vie privée etc
bon voilà on avait fait un petit peu
beaucoup sur cette affaire de dessins
caricatures je suis pour la transparence
maximale je suis pour l'information
maximale je suis pour que tous ceux ça
j'ai pas de problème là dessus
après moi je trouve aussi que les
intégrismes sont quand même extrêmement
préoccupant d'ailleurs je me dis aussi
aux autorités religieuses
ils sont pas sont pas là pour justement
brider la liberté de la presse et sont
là pour dire aux fidèles qu'il faut pas
tomber dans l'intégrisme et qui foirent
beaucoup de recul par rapport à ça et
puis quand il ya manifestement et c'est
le rôle du premier ministre un risque
pour l'ordre public parce que sexe et sa
l'objet sur un truc ridicule c'est que
le film américain l'a aussi ridicule
nuls aussi que y ait des gens qui
exacerbe les tensions diverses et
variées à seulement de l'ère de
l'intégrisme religieux pour forcer le
trait le premier ministre libanais en
raison de l'internet manifestations et
je suis très à l'aise pour le dire
alors ma changer de sujet on va revenir
sur les journées parlementaires elle se
passe jeudi à dijon et c'est celle du
parti socialiste ça se passe donc à
dijon par mois de 30 ministres quatre
cent cinquante parlementaires une
première pour de nombreux députés
mais il ya aussi été marquée par
quelques grogne et mécontentement les
thèmes ne manquent pas traités européens
mais pas seulement pas facile de
défendre l'héritage de martine aubry à
dijon harlem désir est accueilli par un
sénateur maire qui n'a pas du tout
l'intention de céder l'un de ses mandats
j'y tiens beaucoup parce que c'est un
facteur de renouvellement de promotion
de deux jeunes ça aide à la parité
donc on y travaille avec tous les
parlementaires mais j'ai pas pris cet
engagement parce qu'on me l'a pas
demandé je voulais déjà dit donc faut
pas confondre ceux qui ont pris un
engagement cosigné une lettre
d'engagement
c'est leur responsabilité et ce qui
avait été lu avant
auquel martine aubry d'ailleurs n'avait
pas demandé de prendre cet engagement
la loi ne peut pas très trop active et
la jurisprudence aubry non plus martine
aubry avait demandé à tous les
parlementaires de s'appliquer le non
cumul avant la fin septembre
une nouvelle règle du ps qui ne sera pas
suivi par tous les grands élus
socialistes
la direction du parti refuse de parler
de sanctions mais une loi sera mise en
chantier dès que la commission jospin
aura rendu ses conclusions durable donc
bien un texte de loi sur le cumul des
mandats qui traitera à la fois de la
question de la limitation des cumuls les
indemnités ça pourrait arriver très
rapidement et dès la loi de finances
rectificative et puis de la limitation
aussi des fonctions par les ai vu que
cet engagement il sera tenu
avec la fin du cumul des mandats c'est
aussi une exception française qui va
disparaître
soyons clairs la vème république s'est
bâtie avec l'idée de dire on va leur
permettre le cumul des mandats comme ça
ils seront pas trop souvent l'assemblée
et il n'en mettront pas l'exécutif
là il va y avoir des députés qui seront
présents dont l'essentiel de l'activité
sera le débat parlementaire la
proposition le contrôle et donc il faut
aussi repenser ce que doit être
l'activité des parlementaires
le texte devrait passer le cap de
l'assemblée sans encombre mais le sénat
risque d'être un obstacle plus difficile
avec une majorité de gauche un peu plus
courte et dessinateur très attachés à
leurs mandats locaux
jean vincent placé vous pensez donc que
ce texte aura du mal à franchir l'étape
sénat n'était ni dans la vie seuil à
l'arithmétique quand même qui rappelle
aux réalités et des exceptions pour les
sénateurs ou pas dans le cadre de cette
non non moi je suis pas pour les cibles
sur sénatoriales je suis pour
l'application de la proposition encore
voyager d'autres et soutien au président
un public soutien au premier ministre
une loi et qui luttent contre le cumul
des mandats un mandat parlementaire un
mandat local non exécutif comme
actuellement les ministres se sont
appliqués son sens en droit d'ailleurs
et je crois que c'est vraiment
extrêmement important que les
parlementaires justement je le disais
moi je suis pour qu'on revalorise le
fait puisse avoir plus de moyens pour
travailler et et collaborateurs et ses
expertises
le sud mais aux frères sénateurs ils
disent il nous faut un ancrage local
non mais ça c'est leur alimentation -
mon argumentation soir au sénat présent
qu'on soit utile aux collectivités
locales ça c'est important et je pense
qu'avec le mandat local justement à côté
on sait mais c'est pas un conseiller
général conseiller régional
on y voit là quand on est dans une
collectivité et qu'on est en plus
parlementaire on écoute beaucoup donc il
ya pas besoin en plus d'être dans
maire-adjoint ou vice président ou
présidente département qui va les
indemnités vous êtes pour aussi oui oui
oui vous avez entendu monsieur vidal moi
je l' ai déjà dit ces histoires-là des
indemnités faisons ce que les français
veulent même si on compare les coûts il
ya beaucoup de rôles antiparlementaire
tampon janice mais ça au moins ça permet
de sortir seul et gratien je dis non non
non mais franchement c'est pas le truc
essentiel parce que par ailleurs aussi
temps il y aura le statut d'élu local
parce que comme justement le nommé mr le
maire par exemple ne sera plus députés
aux sénateurs il ya énormément de mer
qui vivent très chichement des
indemnités qui travaillent à côté parce
que pour le coup il ya un autre cumul
c'est le cumul de mandats électifs avec
une activité professionnelle etc
donc je vais vous dire dans une
démocratie qui se respecte et qui ne
veut pas être censitaire c'est à dire où
il n'y a pas que des gens fortunés ou
des professions libérales il faut payer
ses élus donc il faut pas non plus les
payer énormément parce qu'on voit la
crise telle qu'elle est il faut donner
l'exemple il faut les payer il faut la
transparence soit maximale il faut
respecter la fonction d'élu parce que
vous savez un moment tout le monde qui à
certains niveaux de d'éducation ou de
savoir va plutôt s'orienter vers les
métiers de l'argent vers les métiers de
la communication etc etc et maintenant
je le dis parce que attention
aujourd'hui il faut la fonction
politique est une fonction noble elle
est extrêmement importante et très
sincèrement quand à 25 30 ans le
s'engager dans la politique je vous
promets il ya personne qui est sur la
question des indemnités à peut-être la
question du pouvoir
mais la volonté de faire des choses
pareilles nos citoyens oui oui voilà non
mais attention après pour tenir compte
de l'opinion donc moi je suis d'accord
si c'est proposé on le fera mais ce qui
est important c'est que le cumul
s'arrête
qu'on soit vraiment au sénat en soit
vraiment à l'assemblée qu'on bosse et
pas seulement dans la confection de la
loi en amont mais dans le contrôle après
ça c'est très important et la question
de l'évaluation des politiques publiques
parce qu'aujourd'hui d'efficacité a
dépensé très attendu également
on le voit bien pour cette indemnité de
monde voit surtout pour les
investissements pour les transferts
hélas là il ya un vrai sujet politique
de fond d'être extrêmement attentive ça
permettra le renouvellement des
générations politiques plus facilement
oui oui non je vois que des avantages au
non cumul des mandats gens nous avons
toujours été pour et permettez moi de
vous dire que chez les écolos on est
plutôt précurseur sur le sujet donc
voilà on va terminer cette semaine avec
cette étude édifiante quand même
commandé par un comité indépendant sur
l'effet des ogm
les travaux montrent l'apparition de
tumeurs chez les rares dès le 4ème mois
de consommation l'étude évidemment on
relance la polémique sur la consommation
de gm est aussi se prennent des
expériences menées pour l'instant par
les producteurs de gm jérémy hartmann
des images chocs qui font frémir partout
dans la presse ce matin les mêmes photos
de rats littéralement déformée par des
tumeurs grosses comme des balles de ping
pong pendant deux ans ces rongeurs ont
été nourris au maïs transgénique
les résultats sont dévastateurs les rats
malades sont deux à trois fois plus
nombreux que ceux nourris au maïs
classique menée dans le plus grand
secret par une équipe de scientifiques
français
l'étude relance le débat sur la nocivité
des ogm pour l'homme le gouvernement a
immédiatement saisi l'agencé nationale
de sécurité sanitaire pour expertiser
les résultats
si les conclusions de cette étude sont
validés
rapport à ce qui est présenté dans cette
étude les risques de toxicologie et de
toxicité ayant été prouvée à ce moment
là des décisions importantes seront
prises et en particulier au niveau
européen pour interdire l'importation de
ce type d'alimentation c'est la première
fois qu'une étude aussi longue est menée
sur les ogm deux ans d'expérimentation
alors que la durée maximale des
précédentes recherches n'a jamais
dépassé les 3 mois l'expérience a été
menée avec du maïs transgénique nk603
traiter avec l'herbicide roundup de la
firme monsanto
sa production est interdite en europe
mais pas son importation jean vincent
placé on voit un mille des cultures
france est très réactive sur la question
oui je suis très content de la
réactivité de stéphane le foll je crois
que il a pris conscience du danger que
nous attirons nos des écologistes depuis
longtemps sur le problème des ogm alors
toujours rimé vous êtes content relation
ce qui sera non n'est pas du tout contre
la science à vous dire qu'aujourd'hui
ruthie de la recherche sur les ogm c'est
pareil important il faut appliquer le
principe de précaution une proposition
de loi garantissant l'indépendance des
études scientifiques comment on en
arrive à ce que parmi les 200 études qui
ont été faites sur le sujet la plupart
ont été financés par de grands groupes
bien connus monsanto basf
vous allez rire si j'ose dire c'est que
ce sont les deux principaux
producteurs de ces ogm et profite à 3
oui tout à fait trois quatre mois et là
pour le coup d'études a été fait il ya
deux ans eh bien nous nous voulons faire
en sorte qu'il y ait une part de la
recherche publique qui puisse se faire
sur ces sujets et que quand il s'agit de
recherche privé les choses sont
extrêmement clair qu'on sache qui
financent et dans quelles conditions
et c'est pour cela qu'aujourd'hui on
doit avoir une indépendance de l'
expertise qui est un vrai sujet qui doit
être indépendante d'ailleurs je le dis
des écologistes est indépendante des
grands groupes privés parce que ça peut
intervenir sans l'europe sur cette
question alors nous nous avons déjà pris
des décisions au niveau national on ne
fait pas de culture par exemple du
fameux mot son temps ou 1 800 disent
inquiets permis en europe qui de ce fait
notamment en espagne et le choeur du
tonnerre oui il y en a deux qui sont
permis et on ne fait pas la culture du
tout et sur l'ena 46,1 je crois qu'ils
sont qui sont qui sont permises au
niveau européen
il ya un débat que nous deux nous nous
portons les écologistes principe de
précaution interdiction de la culture et
puis aussi le fait que l'on tolère le 0
9% dans des ogm dans les produits vous
savez nous en vous en avez plein dans
les céréales dans les sauces des plats
cuisinés etc etc
et je pense que on a une doit avoir une
vision citoyenne une vision expertise et
que ça devrait être interdit le plus
vite possible
ça va la france l'a interdit l'europe
elle préconise on n'en conservait des
frontières on ne produit pas on ne
consomme quand même dans les produits
que kylie a dans le supermarché il y en
a et donc ça il y à une information à
faire au niveau des citoyens sous le nom
d'epo l'interdition bien sûr la
situation est donc il faut informer
citoyennes et citoyens et l'alambic être
moins marqué sur sur leur maladie oui
c'est déjà le cas donc on sait au dessus
de 0 9% mais c'est pas suffisant donc
sans affoler les gens est ce qu'on est
véritablement face à un problème de
santé publique n'a mais il faut affoler
les gens c'est qu'est-ce que ça mais
c'est quoi le sujet c'est que depuis
je suis désolé se prendre un peu de
temps là-dessus mais on est 7 milliards
aujourd'hui
on sera 9 milliards dans 30 ans
effectivement en 1930 ont été 2
milliards pour qu'il ya eu des sauts
technologiques fabuleux dans
l'alimentaire recherche d'innovation on
est pour ca permis de nourrir la planète
aujourd'hui qu'est ce qui se passe on ne
s'est pas seulement nourrir la planète
on essaie d'intensifier à fond pour le
libéralisme capitaliste maximisation des
profits etc
et quand je dis ça des grands groupes
jeu ça fait de révolutionnaire mais
c'est très inquiétant
et voilà pourquoi nous sommes très
attentifs quelques nous sommes très
inquiet et c'est pour ça la question des
pesticides ogm pesticides agrocarburants
que nous portons le diesel aussi le
kérosène c'est c'est extrêmement
dangereux et ça des zapa de santé
environnement énorme et je suis content
que cette étude ait attiré l'attention
sur le sujet à la lutte continue merci
beaucoup jean vincent placé merci d'être
venu dans notre émission par le moins
d'eau merci merci on se retrouve à la
semaine prochaine mais mieux les moeurs
merci